okay people joining this livestream this
is probably quite brief meeting about
databases and their rotation in version
12 okay operator forms so what is this
so at the end of our talk we were
approached by a Saturn alum who are
writing books about data science with
Northland language so I guess we should
at least discuss it yes absolutely
okay so what is that point their point
is that they liked to rather than
lasting expression one into the other
they like to compose them so first of
all that is the correct form that entity
class thing there it's in fact entity to
class country g8 correct yeah okay so
that's what that is okay so now entity
sort identity class okay what is sort
identity class so in this case you would
put g8 as the first argument and
population okay so they are asking for a
so the problem there is that there's a
third argument to sort identity class
well I mean we've had this issue many
times before the question is whether the
two argument well the would I the one
argument form can clearly just be a
property right
yeah so I don't think that's problematic
to have that be a property um
okay which arguments of air arcs
so shorter than three classes mark
aggregated and two classes Varg
sentences so to which entity class
functions are we talking about here so
we're talking about
should a slash star be slash slash
yes I would think so I mean I was gonna
up then apply the whole thing to just
country no that's crazy
no no this thing there's no reason to
make entity class have just that right
that would I think that's a mistake
entity class should just have its
standard form there well why I mean what
I'm saying is that II empty glass is
just like the others if you're young
then because at some level why not have
that but has a different form I mean
this is a different kind of thing this
is by
oh you're saying that this could apply
itself to the class that this here could
be a class
you
but I think the biggest problem is with
with sub values of the stuff that are
actually doing entry value rather than
whether it's some be use with three or
two arguments etc I mean we're
introducing an evaluation semantics here
so I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm confused here
so this particular thing okay what what
are you saying I'm not I'm not sure I
understand what I'm saying is that even
if these were all were all with a
definite number of arguments I think
that the fact that we are using sub
values for that is the thing that is
most confusing I think it's totally a
different point I understand that's a
completely different point
it has nothing to do with this look what
you're asking for is whether sort
identity class should be able to have
the sorting property here as something
that can be applied to write Tony are
you here yes okay whether this is
something that can be applied to an
entity class right that's what you're
basically asking
oh I see I see while you're talking
about somebody's sorry I now understand
why you're talking about
right I switch a say so that the sub
value here this thing in order to make
use of it here and that slash scar
that's why you're doing that rather than
slash slash I'm gonna make use of it
in order to make this fair ogz I'm sorry
in order to make this an operator form
the sub value has to not mean anything
different correct
I mean unless we want to do something
with let's just be very very clear what
we're talking about here yeah I think if
we say sorted entity class of country
comma population
if I'm not mistaken that will come a
five for example and now I think with
five it's not implemented yet it's one
of the discussion points so remove the
five okay so then I say something like
population here I will get a list of
countries right yep
with populations okay nice okay so I
think that this is more common than them
this kind of right composition usage and
the right composition is it can be I
mean if you want really want to work
write code like that you can basically
define your own pure functions to do
that so there's no but in particular I
mean yes you is yeah the issue is
whether to support the sub this sub
value form or whether to require that
you use entity value to get this correct
Hey yes yes that's correct that that's
that that's the thing don't push the
okay I just don't understand what the
alternatives are the alternatives are
number one this is done with the sub
value right number two that this
requires entity value to get this
correct yeah okay all right I'm trying
to understand what we're what we're
talking about here okay okay so those
are the two so one use for sub values so
this is one use you know use one for sub
values right this is um you know
extracting properties basically right
okay so use two four sub values
composing functionality right
that's operator forms correct yeah okay
so let's look at what that would look
like okay so that would be this comma
and then we'd say entity class country
if I'm not mistaken oh I don't need then
you need at least a second argument
sorry what
you need at least as the second argument
was why sort identity class I understand
explain but then I'm just saying that
the empty glass with one argument
doesn't exist so far so oh I see yes yes
okay so how do I get all countries can I
say common rule probably yes otherwise
it's a list okay let's check that that
works other way we've got a bunch of yes
okay all right good
okay so then this will be the
alternative will be this
and then then to get
in this case that will be common
population
right to get out your mismatch in the
parentheses but yes
you
Oh
sort identity class of after all you
need another back
okay fine okay I get it okay so those
are the cases basically right so that's
the case
in this case
there is no choice presumably I don't
know whether that's possible I mean in
other words is this supportable could we
do something like this it's that
supportable or is that ambiguous my
guess is that's not supportable I mean I
find it also completely backwards
because like you're you're nesting in
the in the wrong direction the end all
right okay fine so I think we should not
support operator forms there at this
time yeah I also think that if we want
to make the change in the future when we
know better
somebody send back to these guys this
notebook please sure I already in
contact with such Chandra I thought nish
wanted to follow the live stream but it
was very much yeah okay fine okay all
right let's go on tables with no primary
key
so most sane people don't do it but
there is nothing preventing you from
doing it so basically the thing is that
when the database doesn't declare the
constraint for the primary key it
doesn't necessarily mean that there is
no key Parisien or no combination of
keys that is unique so we don't need to
fail entirely because we can't construct
so wait a second you're saying that
there's no entity store that if there if
the in the absence of any primary keys
we don't know how to construct an entity
store from a database is that correct so
in the absence of a primary key we can
construct an T store but for that
specific table we will never be able to
construct single entities unless the
user tells us oh look this is the
primary key 3ds as the primary key or as
the canonical name and there is
currently syntax to do that so we cannot
do it automatically but we can let the
user specified sorry I spaced out for a
minute because I'm confused by lots of
other things here um so should I repeat
yeah actually we have a question on our
live stream that I just want to respond
to syntax would work if you want to sort
by population but then pull out GDP so
let's look at that case okay that
example so we want to say yeah so if I
do this case here yes if I do this sort
by population
and pullout GDP that will just work
right yeah that worked make sense
in fact let me try this just to us
you
magnificent okay
how do we resupport sort by reversed
population it would be published angles
to us and these know ascending but no de
Sena descending but I don't know if it's
in the bills yet yeah it should be like
this yes
magnificent okay it's not I don't really
like this form but but that's okay I
mean we might change it later but LD and
we decided that that was the quickest
fix okay
now explain the no primary key case okay
so ethics at inspection time there is a
constraint that isn't that tables of the
database that says this column is the
primary key and that means let me just
as an example to so I know what I'm
talking about just give me a database to
inspect yeah you should have one from a
few meetings ago well but is there is it
in the example documentation for
something no lots cats we haven't put it
in yet okay but imagine that is just a
table with people names okay let's take
let's take the employees of Wolfram
right now you have first name and last
name to this date those are unique but
there is no constraint that they will be
unique yes so what what you do when you
did a very interesting question whether
in the history of our company only no
they're definitely not unique across
history they're definitely not so far I
believe they're unique yes but not yeah
well there is also the problem that
there are people were getting married
and they changed their last name for
example yes so that's why you shouldn't
just have that but you should have a
unique identifier for those people and
so most most in most cases there will be
a primary key and when you do that what
you're saying is this
this column or this set of columns is
the primary key so if you try to add
another Stephen Wolfram then the
database will complain that you are
breaking the UNIX s so now imagine that
on inspection or table we don't find
this constraint for that for the table
okay
so that is valid syntax dot though
probably not well recommended now if so
if you happen to know that a subset of
the columns is unique the main point is
that our entity construction we need a
primary key we need a unique primary key
for working with single entities yes if
you keep working at the class level them
no unless you do any list you should be
good right so in other words okay so the
problem here is cannot generate enter
the edges with canonical names exactly
okay
okay what is your proposed solution I
mean should we just generate uui so
because these will not be stable so the
if we I mean there is a terrible
solution which is to compute a hash of
all the values of all the columns it's
terribly slow because every time you
want to search for one you have to do a
full table scan it doesn't that's crazy
it's completely crazy if you can't write
to the database there's very easily you
can do so the things we can do is either
we issue a message and we say we're not
registering this table because it's it's
broken for entities or we allow them to
register give them a message let's say
some functionality will not work with
this thing okay so Tony what is your
comment about this my comment earlier
was that we might be able to use
something like row ID hidden property of
tables but that needs to be investigated
if that can be supported or not beckons
now some began support row number but
insert in the middle that changes so
it's like yeah there is really no
solution to this problem well okay so
where is it the main issue is we can't
construct an entity store on our side
luckily we can we can and we can also
perform most of the operations just not
the ones that involve single apps how do
we construct an entity store without
having names of entities because if you
perform all the operations with entity
value and entity class like things then
everything works
you don't need single entities no but I
don't come what the structure of the
entity store is if we were to bring it
into memory as an entity store what
would it look like well I guess you
would look like the way we could
represent any memory is instead of an
association as a list that's the real
difference you have nothing to index
into it it doesn't matter you can
perform algebra
okay well look in terms of what we're
gonna do here clearly you know can we
warn people at the time of inspection
that doesn't assume like this absolutely
we can the question is whether we refuse
to register it completely or if we give
them partial function why don't we give
them partial functionality so always
nothing will break okay
so I mean okay so so what is the message
gonna say um unique primary key gay base
has no unique primary key database does
not have unique kind o database table T
does not have okay right does not have
unique primary keys to find it's
actually technically called the primary
key constraint well but we're gonna try
and say something about what that means
happens so then what we can suggest is
if you know that a subset of the columns
are unique then you can set it in the NT
store yeah because I think there is a
first error which is when you are
automatically trying to create the NT
store you can't get the primary key for
some types all right so yeah I get it
so make up these messages let's look at
them okay okay okay
sort identity class overlapping between
the third argument of sort identity
class and the behavior of sampled entity
class
okay so sort identity class has a number
and sampled entity class
also has a number
well
right with a default property basically
whether default property is some kind of
just ID number but what no no sample
empty glass in general will return
something that is not stable right so
then then what I'm asking is okay so if
I say sampled
if I'm saying samples of sort identity
class of country comma population and
then okay so then this if I say entity
list of this
actually if I said to the list of that
I'll get a happy list of countries I
don't know what all of these countries
are in oh by population Antarctica has
zero
um octagon is missing which is from okay
somebody went missing in Antarctica
unfortunately um okay so then you're
saying sample the entity class
country comma five for example right
yeah I don't think this is implemented
yet let's friend also but this seems
perfectly missing it's just a random
sample of five of these yeah not quite
random either
and you get what you get if you don't
sort thing yeah right okay there's no
problem here Tony yeah the only problem
that if you want to bring up is that
sort identity class in the current
proposal has a certain argument which
duplicates the argument of sample taint
in the class no I don't agree sampled
entity classes are convenience where the
sorting criterion is nothing is some
kind of random internal ID yeah so but
if you want the five four if he wants a
slice and want to sort it then you
sample the sorted entity class I know
but that gives you it seems like a very
good convenience to just be able to say
give me you know give me the top five
sorted by population that seems very
useful and I don't see why we would
support that and the only reason is
keeping that argument for potential
future uses
I mean if he later figure out that we
need that for the ordering that means
early then then we are stuck with this
convenience there okay I don't know
about in built-in entities but on the
database word the only thing that you
might vary when you're sorting is like
for example the correlation if you're
sorting strings
well to be fair you're right that's
sorted this is more like sorted by
yeah it is more like sorted by well look
I agree that it's safer to not use that
argument for this you have to
implemented it yet anyway right we have
but I mean under that beside is
implanted but can I say something about
like the current design is short by
where you have F comma P is strictly
less powerful than having a P for each F
when F is list so the the print main
usage of sort identity class is actually
hitting the details it's the one when
you ever there's that very real thing
that one does stable ordering and the
other doesn't remember um you're saying
in the case of sort identity class Mort
by can take a list as the second
argument that primary
yeah and and and there is a difference
when you have a list of functions of a
function that returns a list those are
not equivalent yeah I understand okay
what this meeting not for this meeting
can we separately talk about that and I
LCC or I LD please so wait wait wait
wait is there somebody here who can yes
okay thanks
um okay my claim is that that third
argument P is the thing that we
currently do with ascending and
descending and we do with per function
per property not globally all right look
the basic bottom line is there's a bit
of a mess between sort by sort identity
class and I kind of agree I'm beginning
to agree with Tony that we should not
you know prejudge this right now and put
that argument in there is doing what
Carl was saying was that the third
argument if it's intended for ordering
will not serve us well I understand that
I understand
I mean I mean it doesn't matter I don't
care very much for that third argument
it's just gonna be a little bit more
verbose for users let's think about this
for a second okay so look first point is
I guess it's an ILD discussion for sort
by and figuring out whether the P and
sort by I mean we've got separate crazy
functions you know reverse sort by and
things like that whether that should be
done with that P thing that ascending
descending thing is kind of a hack which
we don't really want to have to repeat
here but if we're going to do that for
the database case we should do that for
the raw list case okay
yes um okay then
here is should we use up the third
argument of sort identity class with a
fur account
hmm
I kind of think we should because I
think that it's if we had to use it for
a function later it's easier to
disambiguate that from the number oh and
the other thing is that we can put a
number and when you want to you can say
just all comma that or actually infinity
yes
all right let's leave the number okay
unless Tony is absolutely freaking out
about this
Coney is at least silent okay
all right last item here limitations of
SQLite for example so should we have a
question I stream here um ah yeah
lifestream been points out that if
somebody makes the database without
primary keys they don't have a high
expectation of functionality yes but who
knows what weird stuff for they will fit
we'll find out in the wild um because
the user may not be the creator of the
database in fact usually won't be okay
limitations of SQLite okay
by registering computing entity
properties to convert them so yeah so
basically the the cool thing is that so
if you inspect an SQLite database you
can never get a date or a boolean but on
the other hand we're implementing
functions that allow you to get them as
a return value in Mathematica so you can
you can say from unique style of column
that you know is unique style is stored
as unique styles so we could show people
how to basically lift up the types by
registering computed properties yes I
think that's what we should we should
not mess around trying to host Postgres
for this it's just that that's a
completely separate project right we
should just share an SQLite tiny SQLite
database we should have examples that
don't depend on any of this weird stuff
um
then we should also show how you would
take an SQLite database and promote it
so that can have these other data types
okay okay okay so I know 'test that we
have so the remaining thing we have to
do is a big documentation review right
yes
um
[Music]
okay we just
you're out well and where and how that
happens I see that's listed for early
tomorrow um all right fine well we'll
get that at an appropriate time
um what roughly is just just to give me
a sense roughly of what's gonna happen
there I mean how much of this this is
not me writing it all you've written it
right open a sample density class for
example I mean it's not knitted it
doesn't have C also but I've written the
details and and the usage er I suggest
so this is free to review button
you
yeah um okay okay
how many functions are there think six
no they're a lot more than that I mean
this includes all the database right
we're not is that there's three more
symbols for databases well we're at
where's where's the database guide page
do we have that do we make a guide page
already we had started then you are
preparing the keynote for WGC and we
stopped okay I don't even know if you
saved it well actually there was one
that was database link and we're
updating it well that's not radical etc
database connectivity
you
you
I see this is what we were about to do
right so this is where we're gonna start
from so how many functions are that I do
or where's the list of those functions
I mean you can do names star into class
no that's not the only thing you've also
got database on and then there are four
more so there are those plus entity
function database connection that is
inspect and SQL database object in
particular you're saying what are you
saying here database database connection
database inspect okay so how these
things managed to get into this
documentation page with the this is
something it's Andrea who's p.m. in here
yes is that right or who's okay so
something went very wrong here because
these are package functions and they
shouldn't have the same dark blue link
color as the other stuff am I making
sense
I'm saying mmm I'm looking at what
you're saying but uh how they should
look I don't know but I don't like this
okay
and that would be a question for Brian
Vanderloo so the ones that are built-in
system functions look different okay
Brian I think that if you instead of
editing you look at the documentation
with doctors clothes they do look
different they are how can you all right
fine okay so the functions that we need
here database connected what is it what
are the functions called the lab is
connection database inspect SQL database
object
you
okay and then the functions that are
okay what's the main function here so
there's an entity class function
right that's that's the main thing that
represents something it shouldn't go
there not in Nanjing based I don't worry
about where this is going yet don't
worry I just fell getting mr. functions
here okay well I think the main function
is entity value but it's already above
okay well there's going to be a separate
page about relational databases so I
think this is so that we want to make a
new guy page which is called something
like working with relational databases
does that make sense
you
okay so then then the first function is
database is a database connection or
database connect its database collection
that it has properties connecting is
connected in general the collection is
is lazy so you yeah you don't you don't
need to it's disconnect in general
unless things go horribly wrong
hey a connection to an external but it's
it's useful to think about this more or
less like file in URL it's really could
even not exist
okay whatever okay so so
database inspect
you
then we've got SQL database object
okay that's those now what are the other
functions so then we've got entity value
which is basically extract a value from
a database so right
yeah an entity list is also another
resolver sir entity itself represents
right something in a day I mean I
wouldn't put it I will entity with empty
glass like Rory and things so then I
would leave a section with Anton
property Anton function well no first of
all we're gonna have entity class
because that's the main thing you work
with yep in fact those should be up
above but I mean again we're not we're
gonna do this tomorrow
um okay so entity class a
you
um and implicitly defined well a class
of entities that can be implicitly
defined possibly that can be
okay all right so
let's talk to value
well let's see extract to value from an
entity class is that correct no also
form an entity in case it's Reedy
extracted from you need the the D ad
tired did and to the class and Robert
class baseball but okay so what are you
saying entity properties another thing
we should look at yeah and we should and
the property and he function should have
their own group because those are the
things that could go in the second
argument okay
so maybe if this is just for relational
databases maybe we should say that and
the class is represents a whole table or
or a subset there I mean it's yeah it's
a table or a computer table and then we
can say then we can say the entity
represents a role and okay so a table of
entities table of sub table of entities
I mean I think table is table and I mean
every table is a table in terms of the
you know definitions that people usually
use if these are tables obtained from a
query they are called either virtual
tables or sometimes derived tables well
then that's still tables yeah but if you
just leave the table that might mean
something that they are not okay instead
and I wouldn't say event is why don't
you say a table possibly virtual no
we're gonna say entities because it's
got the word entity right there yeah
well then what do you say for entity
okay you know what we're not doing this
right yeah let's do this tomorrow
representation of a table or virtual
table something like that yeah it just
give me a sense of what other functions
we have to document though okay we have
filtered entity class those should go
with them to the glass and again think
filtered entity class and what else
sampled entity class sort of entity
class okay that's a separate thing so
those are we're not gonna put those
above these very basic things like no
absolutely not but I think it would be
good to have a sectional which is all
the things that can go in the first
argument to the value at section for all
the things they can win the second
audience all right fine that's fine but
but okay so filtered entity class is
that right
yeah what's the next one sort agency
class and then sample entity clause
yes aggregated entity club so extended
first before sampled no laughter million
now I think so but before aggregated
okay then aggregated entity class
you
okay the emerge Center class is the
search yes
Bailey suggested that WTC we called
joined which I told them we had already
discussed and explained why it was
confusing to college oh yes I remember
that discussion it's a long discussion
okay so that's all the functions is that
correct yes so now what about entity
store and things like this
yeah have you input it in as well okay
so you've got pages for all of those
functions as they're correct yes um by
the way Seth on our live stream is
suggesting that we should have a better
example for entity store than the
bare-bones we have one that we have Tony
that's for you yes you should do it I
agree
um
okay hands on a live stream is
suggesting absolute time for all date
times and SQLite tables that need
date/time datatype
okay not quite sure I understand that
one okay Seth is saying making Co
exactly what entity registered does will
be useful what can you do in an
unregistered entity store you can you
can just take the unregistered entity
store and do things with it right there
it's just that the name the entities
don't implicitly make use of there of
the entity store unless you register the
entity store that a fair description
Tony yes so if you take the entity store
itself and you evaluate sub values and
things those will work it is in a sense
like using a symbol that it's not
defined yet right well maybe there's
something that is unclear about what's
there right now about that
you
yeah we should probably show in
properties and relations at the very
least what what happens with an entity
so it hasn't been that hasn't been
registered yet make sense Tony yes yeah
and I mean I kind of agree with said
that like Q 1 T 2 e 1 e 2 is a big to
drive yeah well I mean that's why this
is probably better bananas and
strawberries but I I think um I think we
need the T 1 T 2 thing but then we need
some other ones under applications that
are more real um
think that having example with first
name age wait you know so you gotta be
more politically correct you can't have
wait sorry and we have mass was people's
gravity right um okay yeah Seth is
suggesting putting the Titanic dataset
into entered his store
is not a bad idea
you know we should have a canonical
simple entity store that is a more real
example Antoni you should you know
figure out what that should be
oh yeah having the classes bead their
own antitype it's a very good idea yeah
that's nice except that might get a
little confusing with classes of service
on the whatever it was the white star
whatever they were um you know first
class was whatever yeah
entity class that's the steerage class
will be a little confusing here um
okay
at a separate table for cabins on the
Titanic that's interesting okay
[Music]
okay comments from Seth emerged as
confusing because merge means something
different than join you mean the merge
function in our language it's really
drunk
I mean joint itself would be confusing
because it's really not what join is
doing it's really what's drawing across
is doing but then what's the objective
of or the past practice fall off join a
cross joined a cross I mean there is a
perfectly could I mean that would be a
perfectly reasonable you know joined a
cross entity class that's a mouthful yes
it's a mouthful but it's a mouth but
it's a it's a full you know it's a
complicated concept if that's the
correct name I mean I don't know does
the semantic submerged entity class does
it agree with the semantics have joined
a cross yes and it does a little bit
more actually but does it have the same
yes let's rename it okay
I think it's unnecessary but at least we
don't confuse anything um
you
you
yeah yeah I agree so joint joined across
so let's rename that um
or should we aluminum then sorted by and
klas
no because that's unfortunately
disappointingly
sorted by entity class has that
preposition you know stuck in the weird
place
I think we've I think we have no choice
there sadly yeah I see what you're
saying is that since I cross can only
take a plural afterwards then it's fine
it's not confusing right if it were
joined across and the classes get across
is just as a bi and as much a
preposition so Seth is commenting on
selected entity rather than filtered
entity why did we not call it selected
before because because select I mean it
was called entity select at some point
but the problem is that select means
something very specific to people are
used to SQL and it's not the same thing
I say I'm not a big fan of the word
filtered because we haven't used it
elsewhere well anyway um
boy I'm about to collide with three
other meetings here so um I think we
have to wrap right now yeah to be
continued um I think it'd be great if we
were able to live stream the hour
possibly quite grisly documentation
session so let's figure out how we
arrange timing so that can be done yeah
I mean I would if possible I would avoid
doing it at 8:00 p.m. on a Friday night
but whatever we'll figure out a time um
okay okay I will commit these changes um
and to be continued okay thanks
everybody thanks to the folks on
livestream so okay